here with a lot more on this and so much
more Secretary of State Mike Pompeo mr.
secretary great to see you thank you for
being with us you actually brought in
Chinese representatives to your office
on this very topic of blaming the US
military and other issues can you bring
us inside that conversation Sean thanks
for having me on tonight we did in fact
call on the Chinese ambassador and I
spoke to my counterpart in China a
couple days back this disinformation
campaign which began when we began to
call out this this risk that was created
not only for the Chinese people but now
we can see people all across the world
where the Chinese government I knew
about this risk had identified it they
were the first to know and they wasted
valuable days at the front end allowing
hundreds of thousands of people to leave
Wuhan to go to places like Italy that's
now suffering so badly they tried to
suppress this information he talked
about the means by which they did it
instead of trying to actually do the
work to suppress the virus which is what
the world demanded and the Chinese
Communist Party didn't get it right and
put countless lives at risk as a result
of that mr. secretary are you do you
believe now that the information which
could be valuable to the rest of the
world we we can get information that
would be helpful at this point do you
believe that information is accurate
that they're sending over now this is
one of the most important questions
Shawn
we have had an incredibly difficult time
getting professional medical people in
you'll recall early on we offered to
have America's finest experts travel
there to assist them to assist the World
Health Organization
we weren't permitted in these are the
kind of things that the Chinese
Communist Party has done that have put
the world in the world's people at risk
they haven't been sufficiently
transparent and the risk Shawn that you
find with we don't get this right if we
don't get to the bottom of this is this
could this could be something that's
repeatable maybe not in this form maybe
not in this way but transparency matters
it's why when we see them forcing
journalists out when we see people who
have been talking about this Chinese
citizens who have been talking about
this no longer having access to the
Internet no longer being able to speak
openly and freely there's risk there's
questions and it's important as a
America's most senior diplomat we have
an obligation
to try and help make sure that we get
this information from the Chinese
Communist Party so we can help our
medical professors here professionals
here in the United States get this right
and save lives for Americans and for
people all across the world
mr. secretary we've known each other for
many years I think if my memory serves
me well I think you graduated one in
your class at Harvard I'm not sure I'm
pretty sure you were right up there if
the Chinese had early on come to you and
said hey we have a problem
how quickly would you have acted to
mobilize America's best greatest medical
researchers scientists the doctor
pouches of the world to immediately
assist them in whatever problem they
were having Sean I didn't cry graduate
first in my class I was I was a good
enough student but make no mistake and I
think one or two I know it's something
we we would have responded immediately
indeed we did all of the experts from
all across both from government and from
the private sector wanted access to all
of the information about the structure
of this virus all the information that
would have permitted us not only to
start on mitigation and cures and
vaccines but also it allowed us to
identify the way that this virus spreads
and to begin to take the actions that
could have kept this virus in a place
where unfortunately we've not been able
to keep it so far let me ask you I read
comments that you made about the
Iranians you know I'm not a big fan of
Iran or Russia or China but putting that
aside it would be helpful if we could
help them I want to ask you about that
and I keep hearing about these kids on a
mission trip and Americans on a mission
trip that a lockdown in Peru and I
believe your office have been active in
trying to get them home safely so let me
take the second one first the State
Department's doing everything we can to
protect American citizens all across the
world we know of students that are in
Peru some other travelers that are there
as well there are other countries to
where those countries have shut down
their airports we are working to try and
solve problems for each of those
American citizens we just learned about
them over the last couple days it'll
take us some amount of time but no the
president Trump has made clear that
we're going to do everything we can to
get every American home safely
as for Iran the same true for North
Korea these are countries that we have
deep differences with and we are working
diligently to create a better conditions
for their people and part of that is to
make sure that we're available to
provide humanitarian assistance when we
can and so we have offered to both the
North Koreans as well as to the Iranian
people humanitarian assistance and we've
offered to facilitate humanitarian
assistance coming into those countries
from UN organizations from other
countries as well we'll keep doing that
it's the right thing to do in a time of
crisis all right mr. secretary Mike
Pompeo thank you as always for being
with us important issues we appreciate
the time